[Music]
all right people we're live on the
internet I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report it's January 17th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
and YouTube Share subscribe tap that
notification Bell postgame show Ruben
report.
locals.com and we have a huge huge huge
show for you today I might have set the
record with the amount of paper on my
desk I sat down early we feel it's tight
and trim and pointed and effective so if
you are not comfortably in your chair
yet let's get you in there and get ready
to roll uh the theme of today's show is
a bit of what we went off of yesterday
uh in light of these Iowa results and
that it does seem that Donald Trump is
the presumptive nominee for the
Republicans anything can happen it
doesn't change any of my feelings that
I've been telling you for the last year
about Ronda santis and all that stuff
but it you got to if you're Dan santis
or even if you're Nikki right now the
one thing that you have to do is lay out
your path like it's not about having
another debate it's not about having a
town hall or anything else it's about
like hey Trump won Iowa here's what's
going to happen in New Hampshire here's
the path going forward for me I haven't
heard either one of them say that yet if
it's there I'd love to hear it but
that's not really what today's show was
about today's show is about what the
reality of the situation is right
because as I always say to you guys I
don't demand the world just sort of Bend
to me I'm a realist I see the world as
it is and then I operate accordingly so
what we are going to talk about today is
If Trump is the nominee how do we help
him level up right now because between
the Deep State and that swamp and now
the world economic Forum which is having
their annual meeting in Davos
Switzerland right now there are going to
be major major issues that this guy is
going to have to deal with on top of the
fact of the media going after him and
the court cases and everything else so I
what I don't want to do for the next
year is sit here every day and be like
he's the nominee and I love him and I'll
never criticize him and that there's
plenty of other shows you can watch for
that uh but what I do want to do here is
try to hold him to a higher account show
you that if he fails us that there are
other options and they actually still
are other options and that we can
actually fight for something a little
bit better so let's just freaking dive
into all but oh and I want to start
actually with the with it's going to
seem like a bit of a sidebar but I think
you'll you'll find follow me there I
want to start with a clip that was going
viral over the last couple days it's a
clip of Bill Mah standup this is from
about 20 years ago I think this is
around 2003 an HBO special that he did
Bill Maher he still considered himself a
liberal now right he's like one of the
one of the last liberals now non-woke
liberals uh but 20 years ago was
certainly within what the mainstream
liberal position was okay it's not the
mainstream liberal position anymore say
defending Free Speech individual rights
anti-ra actual anti-racism Etc
uh but Bill had uh this clip going
around about the in that you should be
intolerant of intolerance and I think
that'll set us up nicely today but you
have to understand you have to embrace
the values of Western Civilization are
not just different they are better okay
I know a whole generation has been
raised on the notion of
multiculturalism that all civilizations
are just different no not always
sometimes things are better rule of law
is better than autocracy and theocracy
equality of the Sexes better protection
of minorities better Free Speech better
free elections better free appliances
with large purchases
better don't get so tolerant that you
tolerate
intolerance remember what happened to
rushy he wrote a book it got mixed
reviews some people liked it some people
wanted his head on a stick no one should
have to die for writing a book with the
exception of the bridges in Madison
County I
will all right that's great stuff and
that's 20 plus years ago and it's true
it was true then and it's true now what
he's referring to actually is known as
Carl Popper's Paradox of Tolerance right
you want to be so tolerant that you let
everybody in and every idea and but if
you do that with no guard rails no
intolerance for the intolerant people
the people that want to chop people's
heads off and kill you if you draw a
cartoon and all of that stuff then you
are going to just end up impaling
yourself right and isn't it interesting
because the the specifics that bill
mentions there things like defending
Free Speech defending equality he says
equality not Equity he's talking about
Law and Order these are all the
conservative principles of 2020 before
you all know how the the Spectrum has
shifted on that but what I want to do is
apply that standard the standard of
intolerance uh of intolerance of
tolerance to Trump and sort of every
everyone that is now going to be the
players going forward this coming year
that's how we're setting this thing up
and before I get to it let me talk to
you about gravity to Fire Shoes guys I
want to take you on a journey behind the
scenes of the shoe industry where we'll
uncover the stark contrast between a
premium shoe maker and those simply
riding on massive advertising budgets
buckle up as I unravel the insights
gained during this eye opening
exploration enter enter G defi shoes a
true departure from the ordinary backed
by a groundbreaking clinical study
conducted by UCLA now picture this While
others have clung to shoes featuring
run-of-the-mill memory foam soul for the
past five decades gy stands apart with
its patented and meticulously designed
so Construction this isn't about
absorbing shock it's like your shoes
giving you a high five for every step
boosting you forward and adding pep to
your stroll gy isn't going for the easy
way out they're not just grabbing any
old soul off the shelf no they're on a
mission to boost the biomechanics of how
shoes work and fostering a movement that
nurtures your body Now While others
question the adequacy of their Footwear
G defies is in the business of creating
Miracles it's not just a shoe it's an
immersive experience a device that
alleviates pain and serves as natural
Footwear to preempt further their wear
and tear trust me you want to be part of
this revolutionary journey and I'm
thrilled that I finally am gy doesn't
pour Millions into celebrity
endorsements uh to entice you although
you might have spotted G defy on some
famous feet instead their investment is
channeled into the foundational
construction of the shoe but don't take
my word for it explore the multitude of
reviews and testimonials from ordinary
individuals who attest the miraculous
impact of gy shoes on their lives
available at the gy website and
platforms go to gy.com now because your
feet deserve more than another PA shoes
and here's a little extra love for our
podcast listeners use the discount code
Ruben 30 for an exclusive $30 off your
order of 150 or more Yes you heard it
right a little gift from GFI to your
feet experience the miracle that is GFI
and now back to me okay so what we do
not want to do is be tolerant of
intolerance right we need to all level
up what we're doing the Liberals
unfortunately in the last two decades
didn't level up right they didn't heed
the warning of Bill Mah right there he
was talking to an all liberal audience
guys stop being so freaking tolerant of
everything not every idea is good okay
and now I want to apply that to what's
happening right now because Trump
obviously is the
presumptive nominee anything can happen
right like the guy could fall down the
stairs the court case anything can
happen but conventional wisdom he's the
presumptive Nomine at this point uh what
I want to see out of trump is a degree
of not just we're going to do this thing
all over again so first I want to to
show you a little video of uh Trump
yesterday in New Hampshire if you want
to
defend your honor and if you want to
defeat the radical left Democrats and
save America you must vote for your
favorite President of all time Donald J
Trump next we okay so that's Trump being
Trump right I'm your favorite President
we're going to defeat them they're bad
I'm good blah blah blah that's all just
fine right and that's the Trump that we
know and it's the Trump that many people
love it's the Trump that I voted for
before okay fine we can support him but
I think what we have to do now is also
put him on notice so that he doesn't
just sort of fall back into some of the
bad habits some of the bad habits of
hiring the wrong people trying to make
deals with Democrats who are always
operating in bad faith always propping
up the mainstream media as it's trying
to take you out uh and maybe also
realizing that you've made some mistakes
along the way I want to jump back uh
this is now six years ago but this is
2018 this is Donald Trump anti-globalist
anti-de State Donald Trump at the world
economic Forum which again is happening
right now they're having their annual
meeting and here he is with CLA Schwab
well we've loved it we think it's a
great country a beautiful country and we
have had a tremendous success yeah great
success and this gentleman as you know
he's uh he's done a great job thank you
very much thank you one more question
all right so this gentleman CLA Schwab
who's the leader of the globalist
movement there's Donald Trump six years
ago saying he's done a great job so what
I want to do is apply Bill Maher's uh
argument that that Paradox of Tolerance
uh to Donald Trump right now right we
have to be able to call balls and balls
and Strikes we have to be able to be
intolerant of some of the bad ideas
while we do see the writing on the wall
that he is the likely nominee or we can
just kind of bow to him right we can
just bow to him and nothing will ever
get better it's not as if Donald Trump
in and of himself at 78 years old or
whatever he is is suddenly going to
magically get better magically start
thinking things a little bit differently
at this moment now he's done a lot of
good in all of that right and he saw
something years ago that helped a whole
bunch of us see the world maybe a little
bit more as it is right you know through
the without the fog of mainstream media
but what I think we cannot do is is just
bow to him so I want to show you a video
this is this is two days ago because VC
is now campaigning with Donald Trump but
I want to show you a video two days ago
where VC is on the campaign Trail so
this is on Monday on caucus day trying
to explain to this woman that she has to
vote for him to save Donald Trump
meaning she has to vote for VC to save
Donald Trump take a look oh they are and
they will stop at nothing but we're not
going to let them get away with that
I've got fresh leg I'm not wounded
they're not going to let this man do it
you know when you said eliminate that
gave me a chill I'm scar because you
think it's false or because you think
it's true I think it's true I think they
will stop at nothing to stop them stop
drun I it's sad but it's the truth it's
the sad but it's the truth so I'm asking
you do your part and we're going to we
can do this we can do this they say how
do you feel about the United States and
I say I'm worried and I'm fear
my job that you don't have to feel that
way in this country but we're losing you
we're we're losing it it pains me to
hear that we meet people like you young
do this and that's where our founding
fathers were yes it's 1776 moments so I
want your support at that iow caucus I
get emotional I'm emotional about this
country I need your support on Monday
night you do this I'm going to do my
part okay you're you're picking at my
shelf you are yeah but you know I've got
it's about this country it's about this
country you want to save you want to
save Trump you vote for me I'm telling
you that you have you vote for Trump
you're sending him a sledgehammer no but
you're sending him to his own demise
you're falling into the Trap that not
only a country is falling in that he's
falling you want to save Trump you vote
for me I need your support at the Iowa
caucus that's a good AR okay so two days
ago there is VC saying if you want to
save Trump you vote for me I've got
fresh legs I'm not wounded they are
never going to let Trump be president
again vote for me the hug now I get it
he's a he's a he's a Salesman all of
that stuff it's it's all fake emotions
and everything else his campaign was
truth but I'm not I'm not doing this to
pile on V right now I'm not at the end
of the day um candidates I I almost said
comedians candidates see the writing on
the wall and then you end up allying
with people and I do think they had a
deal at the beginning but I want to show
you what's wrong with the tactic that
uh laid out there so he's going around
two days ago they will stop Trump I'm
younger vote for me then he does not do
well in in the caucus he gets about 8%
or so and then he immediately then just
switches over to team Trump the same
exact person who is saying they will
never let him be president uh here he is
yesterday with Trump there is not a
better choice left in this race than
this man right here and that is why I am
asking you to do the right thing as New
Hampshire and to vote for Donald J Trump
as your next president because we're not
working with a lot of time here if our
kids are in high school before we get
this right we don't have a country left
that's what it means we've been
celebrating our
diversity and our
differences for so long that we forgot
all of the ways that we are the same as
Americans Bound by that common set of
ideals that set this country into motion
We Believe those ideals still exist this
man is going to be your next president
to revive them okay so the messaging
that he just said there I agree with all
of that of course I agree with all of
that what I'm trying to show you here
though is that if we don't call balls
and Strikes Again his campaign slogan
was truth there he was saying that man
will never be president then the results
don't go his way and then he's on stage
saying we must support this man if we
just always forget the behavior that
everyone does all the time if we just
play into everyone's delusions we will
not get this thing uh back back in any
sort of semblance of Sanity I just want
to show you this 10-second clip of trump
andc almost kissing here there's there's
definitely some weirdness between these
two because it's clear there was some
sort of deal cut it went a little bit ay
as V got some momentum now Trump you can
sort of see it he feels like VC is kind
of the future he's a little bit sharper
than him and here they are with an odd
kind of kiss moment it's kind of
[Applause]
[Music]
funny good to
see all right so there is some weird
tension there because it's clear to me
that Trump knows he needs VC right
because he's got that that younger sort
of thing and he's an extremely good
speaker and all of that and he's willing
to say anything to make it happen but
Trump also understands oh at some point
he's going to try to take me out so I'm
just putting this down that you can put
a pin in this and and just watch how
this thing all plays out what I would
say though and my purpose of showing you
that was not to show you okay VC flipped
and lied to that woman and all of that
it that I don't think that Just
lavishing Praise on Donald Trump right
now because he got 55,000 votes and
again is the presumptive nominee I don't
think that is the way that we are going
to get out of the bigger set of problems
that we have that we have we have to be
intolerant of intolerance okay we have
to call out our leaders with compassion
and with judgment because it will make
them better we can't just bow now right
because there are options by the way
right if Trump is the presumptive and he
is if he is the presumptive anti- Deep
State candidate and he fails at that
then we are seriously screwed so now I
want to just take a little little side
road for Justus a moment because there
is another candidate that is still
running and is still running as an
anti-de State
guy uh and who does have some momentum
and in this case I am talking about
Robert F Kennedy Jr he put out a video
you're going to have to bear with us
here it's a couple minutes long but we
we discussed whether we were going to
edit it down for this I think it's worth
watching the whole thing and I just want
you to listen to the messaging because
right now what I'm sensing is that
Trump's messaging is it's it's me I'm
back back you all love me let's do it
again like that there isn't necessarily
we're going to fix any of this or my
behavior will be different or anything
else uh that's one version of it and now
I want to listen to another another
version of a vision right and listen to
RFK and his vision right
here this is a day of
affirmation a celebration of
Liberty we stand here in the name of
Freedom we are are committed to peaceful
and nonviolent change we must recognize
the full human
equality of all of our people not just
to those of a particular religion not
just to those of a particular race not
just to the
wealthy but to all of the
people we must do it for the single and
fundamental
reason that it is the right thing to
do
a new twist this morning for the
country's most famous political dasty RF
Jer it's time toal a divided nation and
return the power to the people Robert
Kennedy
J
we are told today that our nation is
hopelessly divided but I found something
different as I travel this country I
have witnessed an upwelling of optimism
that I've never seen before something is
stirring in us that says it doesn't have
to be this way and so I've come here
today to declare our independence from
the tyranny corruption which robs us of
affordable lives our belief in the
future and our respect for each
other but to do that I must first
declare my own
independence independence from the
Democratic
party and from all other political
parties I haven't made this decision
lightly it's very painful for me to let
go of the party of my uncles my father
my grandfather and both of my
great-grandfathers but my sacrifice is
nothing compared to the risk our
founding fathers took when they signed
the Declaration of Independence 247
years ago they knew that if their
Revolution failed every last one of them
would be hanged they chose to place
everything on the line when John Adams
put his pen down after adding his
signature to the Declaration he turned
to those present and he said to them
sink or swim live or die survive or
perish from this day on I am with my
country I'm going to make that same
pledge to you today so that I can stand
before you as every leader should stand
before you free of partisan Allegiance
free from the back room deals a servant
only to my conscience to my Creator and
to
you every president enters office
promising to unite the nation and to
work with people from the other party
across the aisle none of them ever does
it they can't they're already chosen
aside well I'm not going to have that
problem I'm going to build coalitions
from both sides of the aisle
and except for the small minority of
public officials who are actually
corrupt I'm going to tell you this
secret they too want Liberation from the
system that has captured them and isn't
that ultimately what we all want
Liberation from A system that robs us of
our wealth our health our hope our
patriotism our ideals our freedoms and
ultimately our sense of ourselves as a
good and capable people
is healing our divided nation
possible let's go take back our country
God bless you and God bless the United
States of
America I declare my Independence I
declare my Independence I declare my
Independence we declare our independence
I declare my Independence we declare our
independence declare my Independence we
declare our independence I declare my
Independence I declare my Independence
deare me Independence we declare our
independence I declare my Independence I
declare my Independence
[Music]
[Applause]
iare few men are willing to Brave the
disapproval of their fellows the censure
of their colleagues the wrath of their
society moral courage is a rarer
commodity than bravery in battle or
great intelligence it is the one
essential vital quality for those who
seek to change the
world I'm Robert F Kennedy Jr and I
approve this
[Applause]
message okay thanks for bearing with us
on that I hope you I hope you felt what
I felt while watching it now I just want
to get in before any of you who are
probably watching that go and what wait
a minute Dave said that he would support
Trump if the SS was out and now he's
playing a video by RFK and why am I
talking like this I am just trying to
show you that there is a vision out
there that is also good and what I want
to push Trump towards if he is the
presumptive nominee now he is the
presumptive nominee now what I want to
push him towards is a vision that is a
little bit closer to that not just I'm
back and I'm you love me right like and
not and I'm going to get all the people
to bow to me and wave to me and tell me
I'm the greatest but something that is
truly American right to link it to the
Bill Mar thing I want Trump to sort of
start being intolerant of the
that he will be surrounded by because
that is the only way that we are going
to fix this thing and RFK does have by
the way a chance here he does actually
have a chance because we know that only
about 30% of Republicans really love
Trump it's hard to to know what
percentage of Democrats really love
Biden but it's probably around 30% then
you get all these people who kind of you
know pinch their nose and vote for these
guys uh but if you had a viable
third-party candidate who was actually
on all the ballots and everything else
you only need about a third of the
people to like you and he's polling
already around 25% I'm not saying he's
going to be president I have more
disagreements politically with RFK than
I do with Trump I'm just saying I think
this is a moment this is a moment now
where we can sort of push all of these
guys Donald Trump in particular to be a
little bit better I want to show you
this video uh of RFK because he was on
the hoe Mandel podcast uh and there's
still so much confusion over covid and
one of my frustrations with Donald Trump
is that he seemingly has shown no regret
related to lockdowns or related to
operation warp speed or anything else so
if it's like if we don't look back on
that stuff and be like all of us made
mistakes all of us accepted narratives
blah blah blah then then we are doomed
to do it again and I don't want Donald
Trump to make all those mistakes again
Listen to How
effective and and thought out RFK here
RFK is here as he just debunks nonsense
in real time a clinical trial study you
had 22,000 people who took the vaccine
and 22,000 people got the placeo and
what the result was after six months
they had to hand that data at to FDA in
order to get the emergency use
authorization what that data show know
that in the vaccine group there was one
covid death of 22,000 people over 6
months right in the Co in the
unvaccinated group there were two covid
deaths so of 22,000 people so that
allowed the company to tell the public
the vaccine is 100% effective 100 but
that's a that's a misnomer 100%
effective in as far as because I saw
people on the news going well I got the
vaccine I still got Co they never said
you won't get Co they just said that the
it'll kind of pull back the severity of
it so the fact is that's well proven you
had double the deaths without it but how
listen to this okay okay if this makes
any sense to you they say what they're
saying out of 22,000 people there was
one covid death among the vaccinated and
there was two covid deaths on the
unvaccinated 22,000 people
so and that that allowed them to claim
it's 100% effective effective for what
you can't use the word effective you
remember they kept saying it's 100%
effective no they just said it R it'll
neate theity if you go on the internet
you can see Tony fou G but the word
effective didn't say you won't get I
never heard you won't get Co oh yeah
well this is a different subject but
yeah in fact I saw a tape yesterday of
them all of Biden foui Gates uh you know
burla all of them saying if you take the
vaccine Rachel mat
if you take the vaccine you can't get
covid you can't prep past Co I didn't
see that okay well you know what can I
play it for you yeah all
right here it doesn't matter what Rachel
M okay I don't want to relitigate all
that and I know what you were all
thinking as you were watching it yes RFK
you're telling the truth those videos do
exist and you know hoe Mandel you're an
idiot and blah blah blah okay fine my
point in showing you this and I know
nobody wants to relitigate co right now
and I think one of the problems that the
santis had during this campaign is that
everyone thinks we're just on the other
side of Co and it's never going to
matter again so people don't even care
who did the right thing during covid but
but it is important to have leaders who
tell the truth who know what the truth
is and who are willing to continually
stand up and say the truth right so how
about a little bit of Rachel matto
Anthony fouchy Etc saying that the
vaccine is 100% safe and affected it
means that instead of the vaccine being
able excuse me it means for instead of
the virus being able to hop from person
to person to person to person spreading
and spreading sickening some of them but
not all of them and the ones that it
doesn't sicken don't know they have it
and then they give it to even more
people because they didn't recognize
they were right instead of the virus
being able to hop from person to person
to
person potentially mutating and becoming
more virulent and drug resistant along
the way now we know that the vaccines
work well enough that the virus stops
with every vaccinated person a
vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus the virus does not infect them the
virus cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else Dr fouchy thank you for
everything you are everything you do
tell America why they need to get
vaccinated when it is their time and
turn well we need to get vaccinated
because we're dealing with a serious
disease we have a vaccine that's highly
effective and it's safe and that's the
thing that's going to stop this outbreak
the information to show that it's safe
and effective is determined by large
trials and it's been determined by
people who are independent and
transparent it's been examined by people
who have no vested interest except the
health of the American people thank you
Dr pouchy thank you mank you nice to see
you oh God there's so much
there and even them why were they
wearing masks then if they were already
maxed okay you guys get all the
the point of all of this related to our
election right now is that this thing
this thing over the next year better be
about issues and reality as opposed to
slogans and worshiping otherwise we are
completely effed because guess what the
globalists and the world economic forum
and all of these people who have been
telling us what their plans are they are
not going to stop and they would love to
just have a leader who if you just say
nice things about him will do whatever
you want and everything else so for all
the goodness of trump maybe we can
refine him and make him a little bit
better that's why I wanted to show you
that clip of RFK because RFK has
liberated himself from the system now
the system has not been too kind to him
as he has done that right just as the S
this it's ironic in a way because the
system which is not kind to Trump
constantly talks about Trump the system
which if you think about the ideas the
ideas of the system are more are closer
more closely linked to RFK who's a
lifelong Democrat but as he has left the
Democratic party he has liberated
himself from the system and now that the
system is just completely ignoring him
but the point is he is campaigning on
something that is true right of he wants
to destroy the Deep State the covid
craziness all of the the globalists who
want to take away our freedoms and all
of those things just as much as Donald
Trump does and I think he has he has the
the details in his mind to do that so
now I want to jump back to uh the the
wef uh because they are coming guys they
are coming check out klous Schwab
complaining that
libertarianism the individual right you
basically you are the problem from the
world government that he wants to
instill uh implementing their new world
order you have this anti- system
movement what we are seeing is a
revolution against the
system so fixing supress system is not
enough now there is of
course a anti- system which which is
called
libertarianism which means to tear down
everything which
creates some kind of influence of
government into private
lives it's Dem manling the system oh God
he is so disgusting and gross government
in our private lives it's so interesting
RFK talked about Liberation from the
system he's talking about how the system
must control you so again this is where
RFK and Donald Trump have an awful lot
in common and I would say they both see
the same enemy right in our face right
now right they both see that world
economic Forum that globalist agenda the
idea that there will be this one power
to rule us all and individual states not
only in the United States but individual
countries will mean nothing there will
be one government running everybody uh
that is is the biggest problem so the
question is who can beat them uh as you
remember Donald Trump spent some time
with Cloud Schwab I want to show you
that one again for just a second because
we got to keep the pressure on well
we've loved it we think it's a great
country a beautiful country and we have
had a tremendous success yeah great
success and this gentleman as you know
he's uh he's done a great job thank you
very much thank you all right Donald
Trump that's not the Donald Trump we
want now I know some of you Trump people
you're pissed right now cuz you're going
Dave just got a little momentum in Iowa
why would you be showing that well again
I don't think we have to bow to him I
think we have to strengthen him so that
the next time he sees CLA Schwab he's
able to actually stand up against him
because listen to K CLA Schwab right now
at Davos telling us what he wants to do
we risk to become much more
entered and on a n on a national and
individual level to break this cycle
we need a paradigm
shift we must rebuild trust and that's
actually the SE of our meeting we have
to rebuild trust trust in our future
trust in our capacity to overcome
challenges and most importantly trust in
each other okay so this is the problem
what he is telling you is that they want
you at the individual level and the
national level to believe them this is
radically anti-American it's anti it's
anti every country it's anti- Canadian
it's anti- Mexican right countries have
borders for a reason countries have
cultures for a reason reason they're
coming in and saying we want all of it
so I want Donald Trump not to be the six
year ago Donald Trump this is a great
guy over here I want him to be a little
bit more of the RFK I understand what
America really stands for uh check this
out we're going to show you a couple
things now from the w F because they're
telling us they are telling us all of
the things they intend to do and these
are much bigger problems than the
problems that the Democrats the
Democrats are giving us all sorts of
problems on our streets and everything
else these guys are giving us sort of
existential worldwide problems uh here
is the the president of the world
economic Forum uh talking about how they
are ushering in a new world order it's
all good people just a new world order
on the way no big deal that order seems
to know know uh not be
uh the Order anymore we are on the way
to a new order so we are between
orders um do you agree with that or are
there ways of uh what are we able to
keep on the positive side from the old
order to bring into a new world order
and how can we avoid that that New World
Order uh becomes like a jungle growing
back and we rather uh have a order based
on international law and the principles
that that have brought us prosperity and
freedom uh for decades I do think in a
in a more sharp and distinctive way we
are moving into a new era and that's
what I talked about in my remarks that
we are you know the postc Cold War era
has come to a close we're at the start
of something new we have the capacity to
shape what that looks like the guy
answering that question the guy who has
wants the capacity to shape what that
looks like that's Jake Sullivan who's
our national security adviser right now
so we have our own government leaders at
a world economic Forum event saying
basically we will be subservient to you
right we as Americans whatever you guys
figure out here that's what we're going
to Usher into our country it's radically
radically anti-American now I want to
show you a video of the president of the
European commission uh talking about how
uh well you know people like me sharing
this information is mostly
misinformation for the global business
community
Community the top concern for the next 2
years is not conflict or
climate it is disinformation and
misinformation followed closely by
polarization within our
societies these risks are serious
because they limit our ability to tackle
the big Global challenges we are
facing changes in our climate
and our geopolitical
climate shifts in our
demography and in our
technology this is a time to drive
Global collaboration more than ever
before the level of insanity from these
people is off the charts if there's a
chart it doesn't fit on that chart the
top concern of these people is not
conflict or climate now I know in
reality it's not climate they that's
completely made up but suddenly it's
actually that you might think
differently than them that's what they
mean by misinformation these people are
out there thinking for themselves that
is a way bigger problem they've been
telling us the Earth is going to end
right climate's going to what did AOC
say we got 12 years that was like four
years ago we got eight years left but
now misinformation is a bigger problem
than that conflict I mean we're looking
at a war at a war in the Middle East
we're looking at the Russia Ukraine
thing but
misinformation is a bigger problem
because the only way they can get the
complete control over everybody that
they want is if they make sure that
everybody believes in their dystopian
psychotic project check this out
speaking of psychotic projects uh this
is a video of a Harvard University
disinformation expert and she really
wants to push the wef to figure out ways
to shut us all up and it's one of the
reasons this issue has become so vexed
in the United States because now
ordinary people are getting a lot of
disinformation in social media almost
much of which is coming from private
sector interests but then it gets
Amplified when it gets reposted and
resent by ordinary people who think oh
this is interesting I'll I'll pass this
on um but then it's also being Amplified
at the top so I think the private sector
has largely stood by and allowed a lot
of really damaging things to happen
things that in the long run will not be
good for you know liberal Democratic
capitalism and so I really hope that the
world economic Forum will take this
issue on board and think harder about
the role that the private sector can
play in standing up against
disinformation there there's so much
here I mean she wants Li liberal
Democratic capitalism that would be good
at an individual country basis that's
what the Western world has been based on
for the last well basically post World
War II right that's what that's what
it's all about that every country can
have an e Economic Policy we can trade
freely all of those things we have
different countries operating
differently and experiments going on and
some countries work one way some
countries work another they're the ones
trying to crush that freaking thing and
what she's really worried about is as
they usher in the thing crushing liberal
economic uh liberal capitalist
democracies and all that that you're
going to be upset about it so who are
they really upset about uh they're upset
about that Elon Musk guy who by the way
was not invited to the world economic
Forum we're good at saying was this
automatically generated or not and I
think that where saying is this real
information or disinformation that's
actually been a role that goes Way
Beyond Ai and that's a role that
traditionally the media has stepped up
to play and I think that's the right
place for a lot of these questions
around uh this to be centered with the
support of technologist to help us help
you better tell those those stories and
and differentiate truth from fiction I
may sorry I'm going to let both of you
jump in I just wanted to add however not
All Tech cosos admit that they're not
good at every single thing so so I I
thank you for that at least one texi who
hasn't been invited here um who who who
likes to think he's very good at media
as well he's just one of the I hate
those asexual we didn't invite him
because he's a little different from us
yeah the one guy they're talking about
Elon Musk obviously the one guy who has
opened up Twitter so more of us can
share ideas so we can debunk things in
real time so that Community notes their
factchecking apparatus can call out the
from our politicians and from
people like them and that's what they
hate the most so they didn't even invite
him there but okay so if they can gain
control they don't have control of X but
if they can gain control of the rest of
the tech companies and the algorithms
and everything else that's pretty scary
but there's some other scary things that
they have planned uh yeah super covid
have you heard about this disease X this
is the next one on coming on the Pike I
mean they have this thing freaking
planned already and they're telling us
so this is wh president his name is
Tedros his last name is very good it's
tough G Gabus or something along those
how do I do there
gabrius Tedros
gabrius Star Wars character and he's
kind of Star Wars Sith level eil here he
is talking about disease X which is on
the way this is X it's um attracting a
lot of attention and I hope you have
seen in the social media um but it's not
a new
idea um the first time we used the
terminology was in 20 uh
18 there are things that are unknown
that may happen and anything happening
is a matter of when not if so we need to
have a placeholder for that for the
disease we don't know that may come and
that was when we gave the name disease X
you you may even call covid as the first
disase
X and it may happen again
oh you think it may happen again and if
only we had enough control over the
people and if only the people couldn't
question whether they'd be vaccinated or
whether they could go to work or whether
they could wear masks on their face or
every if only we had enough control over
all that stuff then maybe this this um
disease X that we kind of made up that
we've been talking about for quite some
time you get it you get it they are they
are they're showing us they're showing
us and that's why they don't want a free
inter like we have right now that's why
they hate Elon Musk and are trying to
constantly take out Twitter and
everything else uh here let's just keep
rolling uh this is a meteorologist who
is at the WF Carlos
N uh and uh here he is once again
touting the vaccines which is just so
extraordinary but there's nothing that
you can put past these people one
important issue science communication
for instance have we communicated that
the vaccines for the pandemic was they
were created in 10 months fested in
history that saved more than 50 million
lives if it took one more year I mean
have we communicated that well no we did
not there's absolutely no evidence of it
I'm not vaxed he's not vaxed he's not
vaxed he's not vaxed he's not vaxed back
there we've all had covid we're all
doing fine there are a million other
factors you get it you get it but again
this in a weird way it has nothing to do
with covid that's just the thing that
they're using constantly diseases
control those are the it's all those are
all the things that they can use to
basically take away autonomy uh from you
and this this concept that I'm talking
about this is the enemy for 2024 I get
it the Democrats suck but the meta The
Meta thing that we are fighting is this
so let's just keep going uh here is
another person at the wef uh by the name
of JoJo meta claiming that farming and
fishing Must Be Stopped to because
you're going to eat bugs and you're
going to love it I mean EOS side as a
word is becoming more is becoming better
known around the world and the concept
is generally Mass damage and destruction
of nature um but legally speaking um
what our organization and other
collaborators aim to do is to have this
recognized legally as a serious crime
the ecos side what we see is actually
what people are trying to do what
businesses are trying to do is make
money is you know is Farm is fish is do
all of these things that are um you know
producing energy and H business is
trying to make money business is trying
to fish so somebody could eat we're
going to take all those people out as if
these people don't want to make money
they all flew there in their private
jets and the rest of it now let's go
even a step further a step further is
what's really coming on the other side
of this is that once they have complete
control of your mind and your body when
you can go outside what you're allowed
to think who you're allowed to talk to
social credit and all that then you know
who's really in charge at that point
they'll have their good lives right
they'll have their they'll still eat the
steaks and all of that good stuff but
then it will be basically be AI that
will control everybody right the
algorithms what information you can get
and when you can get it so they can make
you believe anything that is what will
control everybody so they are very very
big on pushing AI right now and you need
only read literally any dystopian
fiction novel or watch any dystopian
fiction movie to go oh maybe we
shouldn't hand the control to the robots
but they've got to scare you about that
too it is not necessarily job
displacement but it is absolutely an
impact if you Embrace AI you're going to
make yourself a lot more productive if
you do not then probably I agree with
the minister you're going to find that
you may not have a job so you got to
embrace
it if you don't embrace the AI and the
robots that you won't have a job you'll
eat bugs in the street okay we're we're
I know this is a kind of wide show right
now cuz we started with Trump and all
that so now I want to bring this thing
all together they are telling you their
agenda this is the 2024 WF agenda and
Donald Trump right now is the
presumptive nominee uh to be president
or you know he's running in 2024 to be
president starting in 2025 but it's not
just Donald Trump and uh America that's
having elections right now there are
more than 50 countries having national
elections this year which basically
makes up about half the world four
billion human beings on planet Earth
will be voting in 2024 at least eligible
to vote that's
57% of the global economy which means
roughly 60 trillion dollar of GDP GDP
capital on the line G globally so what
is it that these people will do if they
win the elections right if they get
their Justin Trudeau in if they get
their Gavin news in I think we can go
through it very clearly it's fairly
obvious they will denationalize the
entire global economy right so you will
not have an American economy and a
Canadian economy and and a Mexican
economy will have one economy that's
what that is what the plan is and that's
why they are always looking to install
certain political leaders in certain
countries and then they will
internationalize it right there will be
one thing it will basically be
privatized communism they will have
their stuff but everybody else will just
kind of share and if you don't think
this is happening well we've got some
video of it it is happening in real time
right now here is Ukraine zalinski at
Davos his country is at War but the
guy's constantly traveling around
meeting all these fancy people uh here
he is meeting with the heads of JP
Morgan Chase Black Rock Bridgewater and
Blackstone they control an awful lot of
stuff here he is just saying hi he's at
waras God bless you thank you so
much to
see
all right you might be watching this
going da this feels like Alex Jones
level stuff except it isn't really we're
just peering behind the curtain and
showing you exactly what they are saying
do you think there's a reason that they
want control of the internet because
when they have these meetings to figure
out what they're going to do they're not
thrilled with all of the people that get
to share this stuff on a free internet
because one day once they have complete
control they'll just shut it down so we
got a little window to expose some of
this and again to connect it to where we
started to make sure that whoever our
president is in the United States it
cannot be Joe Biden or whoever the
Democrats are going to usher in because
that's they want all this stuff whether
it's Donald Trump or RFK or somebody
else Ronda s doesn't even matter we just
have to equip them properly to be able
to fight this stuff because what they
want once they have the the economic
control over all our countries is one
government that's it one ring to rule
them all uh listen to CLA Schwab and
2020 thanking China which knows a little
bit about authoritarian control of its
people thanks also to the leadership of
China in terms of fighting the pandemic
in terms of
reinvigorating its economy we have now a
window of opportunity to create this
Global reset which we all need oh so
thank you China China where the co thing
came from China with all that
authoritarian control China with social
credit score China which doesn't respect
individual rights China which is
actually committing a genocide of the
Wagers that's the China we're thanking
and what else can China do once it once
it has complete control of its people it
can literally just flip a switch uh and
it can actually just send you to covid
prison watch this and you remember you
remember some of these videos this is
what what they were doing during Co they
were just putting people in little jails
and I mean there are worse videos than
that they can flip a switch and
congratulations you can't use your
credit card anymore nobody wants to talk
to you anymore and we're going to
basically put you into jail so the the
plan it's gross it sounds nuts I would
prefer to talk about something else but
this seems to be what they want to do
globally in 2024 and that's what they're
telling us so what can we do we can call
it out okay I think we did that here uh
but I think we can also help the brave
people who are calling out this nonsense
so I love love love this video you may
remember ABI yiny I've had him on the
show a couple times he's from Rebel news
he's an Australian journalist he's an
actual journalist without air quotes uh
he is at Davos right now at the world
economic forum and this morning he
confronted John Kerry about flying on
his private planes uh when he's always
worried about climate hypocrisy and you
might we watch this video we thought it
was from last year cuz he's done this
more than once to John krey but this is
this morning what's the carbon footprint
of these events every single year that
you come
here you think it's worth it peasants
pay for your
crimes that's a stupid question is it a
is it really is it is it is it more
stupid than you traveling here to tell
us please sorry we're done we are done
now don't grab me you can't grab us this
is a free Society mate this is we have
freedom of the press why do you think
you're more important your carbon
footprint doesn't matter but everybody
else around the world suggested that
nobody ever suggested that don't make up
stupid questions you being here suggest
that a stupid question you being here
every single year and doing this suggest
that and and I have done a huge amount
listen to it's finished please why can't
I ask him questions please who are you
why are you trying to bully me out of a
no so please that doesn't a lot of
people say no to a lot of the policies
and agendas he
pushes they don't get a choice so why
can't we ask him a question in a public
space can you not touch me do you see
how much these people hate you John krey
has flown more he has a private plane
remember we've shown you the video where
under oath he said he didn't have a
private plane and then the congressman
was like uh but you do and he's like oh
no it's my wife's these people hate you
John Kerrey has put more CO2 in the air
flying private than than than virtu than
I'm sure anyone that you know if you're
watching this show right now and anyone
more than I know they don't care they
will always be eating the fanciest wagu
steaks they will always be flying in
their private planes and all he can say
is that's a stupid question because when
they are confronted on their
they have nothing they have absolutely
nothing they either they are either
absolute Liars or they don't know what
they're talking about in the first place
and speaking of that I want to jump back
to another clip this is about a year ago
Bernie Sanders who has pushed more of
this socialist nonsense on America than
virtually anyone and by the way the
revolution will eat him and it will be
beautiful but you may remember this
Bernie Sanders the Socialist in America
with three houses uh here is Bill Maher
asking him the difference between
equality and equity and he doesn't even
haveing know Dei are we confusing
equality of opportunity with trying to
guarantee equity and outcomes okay
that's interesting because I think this
word Equity has come into the language
in the last few years and before that we
didn't hear it a lot and I think a lot
of people hear equity and they hear
equality that it's the same word and
it's not the same word and the same
concept so how would you differentiate
between equity and
equality well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
come me to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it
not yeah I think so I think that's okay
so which do you come which side do you
come down on uh equality equality yeah
okay everything that Bernie Sanders has
put into the American system and run on
and the Progressive Movement that he
largely birthed in America has been
based on equity and he did not even know
I mean Bill had to drag it out of him
without compl completely embarrassing
him although that should have ended the
grift right there so on one hand if you
call them out on their hypocrisy they
tell you it's a stupid question that's
what John Kerrey did then Bill Maher
asks Bernie Sanders the simplest
question what is the basis of your
beliefs and he doesn't even know the
difference between equality and equity
and the problem with all of that is when
you have a bunch of people who are
either Liars or idiots in charge then
the policies that they create destroy
your lives right because if you think
that people can't make choices for
themselves then generally a bunch of
people who don't care about them are
going to make all of the choices so now
I want to connect this to something
that's going on here in America right
now where we know in most of our blue
cities there are stores closing there
are massive chains absolutely leaving uh
there are migrants coming in taking
services from black people Bernie
Sanders wanted equity for black people
and he ushered in all of policies we
shouldn't arrest people then crime gets
worse we're going to deregulate we're
going to um decriminalize drugs then
drugs gets worse and everything else so
right now what's happening in Boston and
Boston is a hot bed of this Progressive
insanity is that uh Walgreens has
decided to close their fourth location
in Boston because as you know people
just walk in they steal all the the
security guard doesn't do anything
because he doesn't want to get stab
nobody does anything Walgreens thanks to
leftist Progressive policies the same
stuff that the wef would love to have
happening all over the
world Walgreens is now closing their
fourth store and the black residents of
Boston are pissed about it because
people like having drugstores in the in
the neighborhood how do you think they
target black and Dr communities I think
because they get no push back but
they're now getting push back protesting
alongside dozens of other frustrated
customers fighting to keep this
Walgreens open don't we need to have
something in the community to help the
black the elderly the sick you know what
I'm saying they can't go far the problem
boils down to accessibility says former
Boston NAACP president turned Healthcare
Advocate Michael Curry the communities
where they're closing these pharmacies
are communities where people are uh
desperately impacted by disease you know
two or three times higher rates in
cancer diabetes heart disease where life
expectancy can be 15 20 years less while
this isn't the only Walgreens or
Pharmacy chain set to close location in
the coming weeks Curry says it begs this
question what is your obligation what is
your expectation as a corporate citizen
to do what's right for those communities
Beyond what's right just for your bottom
line you see how progressivism destroys
everything right at the end there the
obligation of Walgreens is to make money
Walgreens is a corporation they happen
to be in the business of being a drug
store and they go into areas where they
can make some money selling the products
on their shelves then Progressive come
in and they deregulate crime and they
say go in and steal whatever you want or
this is Los Angeles you're allowed to
steal $800 worth of stuff and then what
happens well more of that crime and more
of the bad behavior happens to happen in
these areas and that's largely because
the Democrat policies uh of handouts to
the black community have created
economic conditions that lead to all
it's it's an absolute you get it it's an
absolute cluster F of of problems but
they have done all of this because they
said give the government the power to do
all this stuff instead of the individual
so Walgreens is not as a what was it as
a Civic citizen he call it's a
corporation but as a Civic citizen
Walgreens should just stay Walgreens
should just stay here and keep losing
money and keep having products be pulled
out of their stores and and no they
shouldn't they should do whatever the
hell they want to do as a corporation so
what is the solution to all of this what
is the solution to the worship of
politicians and what is the solution to
handing off all of your decision-making
power to people in Davos and everything
else well how about first we call it out
that would be pretty good call it out on
the Davos stage that's easy right now
they don't have control over us right
here just yet they have some level of
control but let's call out John kery
right let's call these absolute frauds
out John Kerrey who stands far more for
a one world government than for the
government of the United States and the
man was almost president of the United
States let's not forget then let's call
it out on the American Stage the Bad
actors that we have right here the
Bernie Sanders who apparently don't even
know what they've ushered in or the Joe
bidens who Joe was supposed to be the
moderate who has now ushered in three
years uh of progressive Insanity call
them out uh number three you know what
we could do call out your local
community if they're doing bad things so
if you live in rockberry Boston where
those four Walgreens have closed call
out your Lo local Civic leaders your
local mayor and everybody else who were
like oh you know what we're just going
to decriminalize stuff and we're not
going to have laws and everything else
call them out it's not Walgreen's fault
it's their fault
okay and then you know what you could
also do you could call out the
nonsensical people who rather than doing
good just say they are doing good you
might remember this one from that guy
that they hate about that because this
goes we're talking about power and
influence and I'm saying I'm saying what
what I care about is the the reality of
goodness not the perception of it and
what I see all over the place is people
who care about looking good while doing
evil
them okay
should have just ended the show right
there what else can I add that is the
point all of those WF people all of the
Bernie Sanders types and the John Cary
types and all these people those are the
real enemies they pretend they're doing
good while they are doing evil and until
enough of us are just like f them and
then we're going to coales around a
whole bunch of better people and better
political leaders who are going to get
us out of this mess that's how we fix
this thing not just by worshiping not
just by by praying that somehow it's
magically going to be fixed but by
actually getting a little Sweat Equity
in this and and doing it a little bit
better I know this was a wide show I
know we did a lot I think I I think I
was able to bring it together if you
have any thoughts on that let us know in
30 seconds Ruben report. locals.com
postgame show you can ask me questions
you can comment and all that good stuff
uh by the way tomorrow our 11:00 a.m
show uh our normal 11: am show uh Megan
Kelly will be co-hosting it with me and
we'll be going through what happened in
Iowa and sort of the path for everybody
getting out of there oh and we leave you
with a cold clo we did a little a little
comedy skit as the kids say uh you know
Mark cubin who's been a big fan of
diversity equity and inclusion I decided
that yes I'm 47 years old I got a torn
ACL on my knee um you know 5'11 maybe on
a good day you know I'd like to play for
the Dallas Mavericks so uh we we try it
out next into the tank is a modern
version of a traditional
[Music]
machine hey sharks I'm Dave ruin and I'm
here to try out for the Dallas Mavericks
what are your pronouns my pronouns are
she they how long have you played for
I've been playing for about 35 years but
more importantly my husband's gay what
college did you play at I played at
Howard University a historically black
college oh cool who's your favorite
African-American Elon
Musk and what's your three point
percentage 30% as a she 42% as a they so
what's your vertical high enough to jump
Donald Trump's
wall okay and what would you say your
signature move is funding lower class
abortions from out of state hey what's
your favorite warm-up music The National
Anthem while kneeling all right I like
what I've seen so far you really love
the game but who who is your favorite
player growing up number 32 Carl Malone
sticking all kind of hell up they butt
congratulations man you're the newest
member of the Dallas
[Music]
Mavericks